you think this is the Brian
kilmeade show.
>> Should we expect to be
seeing more lockdowns again new
lockdowns more mandates.
>> You know I don't know George
it's really too early to say we
just really need to. As I've
said it so often prepare for
the worst. And it may not be
that we're going to have to go
the route that people are
saying this we don't know a lot
about this virus. So we want to
prepare as best as we can.
But it may turn out that this
preparation, although important
may not necessarily pushes to
the next level.
>> Does he not understand this
ramifications to preparing for
the worst where you huddle in
the back he declared emergency
EU ban nations.
They understand that there's an
economic and psychological
ramifications, everything that
he does
I don't think a political
leaders do for some reason they
still worship but the throne of
Anthony Fauci Brit Hume FOX
News senior political analyst
joins us now
Britt we've very to talk about
do you like the way we reacted.
>> No it looks to me like we're
freaking out making the same
kinds
of mistakes that we made the
first and second 3rd time
around.
>> So it's so disappointing in
that we have a South
African country who come South
Africa comes phone says listen
I see this variant it. It's
giving us some trouble it comes
to the vaccines were only 27%
vaccinated and we do have
mild symptoms. We're just
telling you about it and there
is in next thing you know the
snap of
a finger Europe Israel. The
U.S. bans these countries ate
African nations. This ripple
effect to that.
>> There are ripple effects of
that and this has been the
issue from the very beginning
of the pandemic and that is it
in our efforts to stamp it out
to stop it in its tracks which
is probably never going to be
possible. We undertook also to
of of efforts
without ever seriously
considering the side effect of
those efforts. You
know Trump. May have made a lot
of mistakes on this but he was
right when he said you don't
want a situation where the cure
is worse than
the disease.
>> When you think is the school
days miss by kids school year
really.
>> How how how much that
contributes to continue the
inequality in educational
outcomes that these poor kids
who know who many was passed
don't even have a computer in
the House who was struggling to
try to to
be educated in this setting
where you know they're really
not in school are really not
getting instruction so on it's
very serious.
>> And and you have health
health outcomes affected by the
fact that people
missed appointments for
screenings and treatment and so
on for cancer and other
diseases.
With the supply chain problems
we're having or a consequence
of covid and the restrictions
that were placed on travel and
on and when will people out of
work and so on so we'll be
feeling the pain from this for
a long time we've never look at
it serious seriously I just
wonder you know you did there
has to be an economic and
psychological important to
every decision made.
>> And I think that the
the so-called experts like
Anthony Fauci just have so they
have one of the Palace.
>> Here's doctor Scott I think
you think you agree needs
pretty competent listen to what
he said cut 5.
>> I think it's unfortunately
very punitive we could have
accomplished a lot of what
we're seeking to accomplish
with these restrictions perhaps
by increasing requirements and
travel is requiring that they
be vaccinating all 7 negative
PCR test in the last 24 hours.
You know these kinds of
restrictions are going to
reduce introductions that could
bias perhaps a couple of weeks,
but we didn't need to close off
travel editor fortune, we're
punishing South Africa for
doing the right thing and
telling other nations that and
you know who want to seek one
strains that they find they
were getting real disincentive
to do that.
>> CDC understand that we were
punishing South ever do we want
to China to do.
>> And you know this the
experience and south of the
Boeing first of all the bomb in
a few cases
of these and the doctor who was
the one of the ones who
reported this is South Africa
who's the who's seen patients
who are not that many but she's
probably seen more than
anybody.
>> So says symptoms experience
so far quite mild and here we
go again. Lockdown shutdowns
travel being shut down people
freaking out stock market
taking and all this as a result
of the continued freak out over
this so we have time and time
again we made the
same mistake.
>> Over and over again so you
know yesterday he took on face
the nation he with Margaret
Brennan, she didn't she Julia
tough interviewer, not with him
as usual. Should this about his
critics cut 15.
>> All I want to do is save
people's lives. And I mean
anybody who's looking at this
carefully realizes that there's
a distinct anti-science flavor
to this. So if they get up and
criticize science. Nobody's
going to know what they're
talking about. But if they get
up and their bullets at Tony
Fauci will people can recognize
there's a person there so it's
easy to criticize, but they're
really criticizing science.
>> And any goes on cut 17.
>> Senator Cruz told the
attorney general should be
prosecuted. Yeah haha I have to
laugh at I should
be prosecuted. What happened on
January 6 Sen.
>> Wow what is it doctor care
about January
6th your thoughts.
>> Well it shows that you know
you get away 6 is a is an
all-purpose now.
Call.
>> and source of of blame.
For all kinds of purposes and
is it that she truck to the
boat to defend himself against
his critics. Although it
doesn't have anything to do
that I
can see with the issues this
disease is just it was just
it's it is reaching for a
weapon comes to hand and I
guess that's what he
that's what became pope.
Well it is what he came up with
what does it mean does it
concern you that he's still in
control of all this.
>> And he's going to be
briefing us with his
with his recommendations which
is like big words at it.
>> He's made a lot of mistakes.
And
it concerns me that someone who
has made that many mistakes
his treated. By so many.
>> As as the man who is
supposed to lead us out of th